hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and today is gonna be hopefully
one of many videos that we make in the
future of said game that game being
cyberpunk now I always like to start
stuff off on a good note but if we start
on a bad note we can always end on a
good note later and that's kind of what
today's video is going to be you've read
the title we're here on CD Projekt Reds
Twitter account and it says we have
important news regarding cyberpunk 2077
s release state that we would like to
share with you
it states we have important news
regarding the release date that we would
like to share cyberpunk 2077 will not be
able to make the April release window
that they had intended and that they're
moving the launch day to September 17th
2020 which I believe if my math is
correct is actually a five-month delay
we're currently at the stage where the
game is complete and playable but there
is still work to be done Knight city is
massive full of stories content in
places to visit but due to the sheer
scale and complexity of it all we need
more time to finish play testing fixing
and polishing we want cyberpunk 2777 to
be our crowning achievement for this
generation and postponing the launch
will give us the precious months we need
to make the game perfect expect more
regular updates on progress as we get
closer to the release date and thank you
for your ongoing support now as you can
tell it is pretty sad to see that the
release date of a very very highly
anticipated game is going to be delayed
it's been happening a lot with other
companies I believe the Avengers game
actually just got delayed and I believe
some other game that I've been thinkin I
believe it's Final Fantasy 7
the remake has also been delayed so it's
very sad to see that but also this isn't
the first time that CD Projekt has done
this before I do believe that The
Witcher 3 back when it before wasn't
even out I believe that was also delayed
due to a few issues that kind of similar
to this and look at that which is one of
the best games of that year I'm pretty
sure it could have been Game of the Year
fit wasn't and some people even argue
that it's game of the decade which I can
totally see how and seeing as they want
to make this one of those games again I
want I'm one of those main people that
I'm totally down for a delay in a game
as long as it's not garbage obviously
there's a huge difference between a game
that has a set release date and then on
releases garbage compared to one that
gets delayed but is better for in the
long run and the worst thing that could
possibly happen is that the game still
gets delayed and yet comes out in
September and then it's still garbage
but honestly the CD Projekt RED is a
solid company and I think they're gonna
do just fine with this game but yeah
like it said there's gonna be a lot more
regular updates and I do plan on keeping
a lot of you guys in the loop for what's
going to be happening in terms of you
know cyberpunk updates so they're gonna
delay it again or is the delay gonna be
gone and it's actually gonna release
earlier than anticipated than the 17th
of September and stuff like that and any
other news that they happen to cover
I'll be covering of course on this
channel and loads of other things when
the game releases so yeah I was always
like to be if you do enjoy guys
subscribe if you're new let me know what
your thoughts are on the cyberpunk
cancellation or delay if you will and
with that take care guys have a greater
day and peace out
you